good morning Hank it's Thursday Hank I
can't talk to you with both my mouth and
my hair so I'm gonna talk to you with my
hair
Hank as you can no doubt see the puff
continues to grow
Hank I'd like to thank the Yeti for her
enduring support of my hair although I
have to tell you I think I'm beginning
to lose the will enjoy the puffs now
because the next time I see you I think
it's gonna be gone
in other news Hank I really want to do a
question Tuesday on Tuesday but I don't
really have anything else I want to talk
about today so instead I'm going to
include some outtakes from last week's
question Tuesday nerdfighters in the
next question Tuesday I'm going to try
to break the world record for most
questions answered in a four-minute
period but I need your help
leave your questions in the comments and
if I don't answer them on the video I'll
try to answer them in a gigantic blog
post at the Ning and now the outtakes
take it away me from two weeks ago corn
dog meets mint chocolate chip ice cream
in a dark alley who wins though I'll
tell you who wins everybody you fry up a
corn dog you stick it in some semi
melted mint chocolate chip ice cream and
you've got the greatest innovation in
deliciousness since the deep-fried
Twinkie what's your favorite graphic
novel of all time there's a lot of great
ones but I'm gonna go with Mouse by Art
Spiegelman if you were going on a long
trip to the evil baby orphanage and
could only take two CDs with you which
would they be a love supreme by John
Coltrane and something by the mountain
goats although honestly it wouldn't
matter since evil baby Stalin is
probably just gonna steal my CDs you get
to have a one-hour conversation with a
Disney character who would it be
probably Mickey I'd like to ask him how
it feels to be single-handedly
responsible for the death of reasonable
American copyright law what's the most
interesting nickname you've ever had one
time in high school I made the mistake
of saying that Christian Slater had
never made a bad movie and for a long
time after that people called me cuffs
why do you think that all the most
viewed vlogbrothers videos are by Hank I
don't know probably because he's funnier
although in one case it seems to be
almost entirely because the screen shot
is of two giraffes having sex I don't
know what that says about the YouTube
community I guess it just says that
we're people who love giraffes who love
giraffes if you had to pick one pattern
to have all your clothes made out of
what would it be
definitely Argyle honestly I don't even
understand the point of wearing socks
unless there are Kyle's what's the most
embarrassing song you know all the
lyrics to when I'm not with you I lose
my mind just give me a sign hit me baby
one more time if you had to vote for
Republican presidential candidate who
would it be
definitely Abraham Lincoln oh wait do
you mean like a living Republican
presidential candidate well first off I
don't vote for the party I vote for the
individual and second off I don't want
to vote for any of those guys why won't
you let Maureen Johnson who is read your
new book Paper Towns talk about Paper
Towns the same reason I won't let Hank
talk about Paper Towns it's secret a
plain Kraft and every single person on
board was killed but there were still
survivors how is that possible
every single person on board was killed
but many married people survived just
one of the many benefits
oh hey riddle I've got one for you
what's the only word in the English
language that starts with PW the Iliad
or the Odyssey the Odyssey has Helen
Hunt scene the Helen Hunt song yet no
keep fighting how old is the Yeti 28
will we ever get to see the Yeti I don't
know maybe if you have a lot of money
and can afford to go on long expeditions
to Nepal which one of the presidential
candidates would you most want to play
twister with mmm that's tough I guess
Mike Huckabee because you know he
doesn't look very flexible and so I
think I'd have an advantage I would want
to play twister with Ron Paul but the
problem with that is that Ron Paul's
version of twister only has yellow dots
because Ron Paul felt that it would
offer more freedom of choice and also be
less expensive if the game eliminated
the red dots the blue dots and the green
dots and also the spinner and now Hank I
will be attacked by Ron Paul's minions
don't hate me guys it was just a twister
joke nerdfighters as always thanks for
your questions
PUF levels I'm going to miss you buddy